beaucoup de discussions beaucoup de
paroles normalement toutes les
revendications qu'on a exprimé lors de
cette rencontre vont remonter à paris
dans les minutes qui ont suivi cette
petite réunion
on espère que que ce ne sont pas que des
paroles en l'air et que tout ce qu'on a
dit sera pris en course et le blocage
continue demain jusqu'à ce qu'on ait
plus soissons et confirmation que
concours à ce qu'on veut qu'est ce que
voudrait créer mais précisément on la
renvoie une révision donnerait une
révision mais à la suppression ou il ya
la suppression de
de la réforme des lycées une révision de
l'algorithme pour des barques ou reçus
ou bien un changement total de barques
ou reçus ou à l'intérim en parcours
super on fait quelque chose de nouveau
on a proposé le faire pour réduire les
inégalités
un concours d'entrée dans les écoles et
les universités
parce que déjà on avait dit que la
manifester que la manifestation se
ça
allez continuer sous trois jours donc
déjà cette promesse là et surtout on
veut avoir la confirmation
la confirmation encore on n'a pas fait
tout ça tous et toutes ces journées de
manifestations cette descente temps fort
de france devant la préfecture convient